hello Matt here the mission of think
fast talk smart the podcast is to help
hone and improve communication for
leadership and career development we'd
like your help to ensure that we achieve
our goal throughout October and November
we'll be conducting a series of polls on
our LinkedIn page to help better
understand how we can be more relevant
and useful to you please visit and
follow the think fast talk smart
LinkedIn page as a thank you to those of
you who participate we're giving away a
coveted think fast talk smart mug to
five lucky winners finally help us
spread the word and share think fast
talk smart with your co-workers family
and friends
I don't know about you but I look
forward to the end of the year many
things slow down the weather changes and
we begin to focus more on family and
friends
unfortunately this time of year can also
bring with it more interpersonal
communication struggles
today we will explore tips and tricks
for negotiating and managing conflict
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to a quick
thinks episode of think fast talk smart
the podcast
we recently polled many of our listeners
on LinkedIn and we found that two topics
many people are interested in are
conflict and negotiation
so we reached out to Michelle gelfand
who is the John H Scully professor of
cross-cultural management and professor
of organizational behavior at the GSB
many of you will remember my previous
conversation with Michelle where we had
a great talk about cross-cultural
communication let's listen in as
Michelle provides us with expert
guidance on how to better negotiate and
manage conflict
this notion of negotiation and conflict
I find this fascinating we've talked
about both topics before on this podcast
with your colleagues like Maggie Neal
and in near halevi and I I'm really
interested to get your perspective on it
do you have some best practices and
advice around how we can negotiate
better yeah I mean I'm kind of a fanatic
about negotiation research and training
sort of quasi-religious about it because
it's so important we do it all the time
with our spouses with our kids we do it
with our employees we do at the
international level and you know I think
research is really trying to explain why
do people negotiate ineffectively you
know when there is a lot of value that
both parties can get at the table like
why do we leave so much value at the
table you know one of the most
fascinating findings is that the best
negotiators tend to be the most creative
for example you know think about me my
husband Todd going on vacation and let's
say this is going to sound a little
gender stereotypical but let's say that
I want to go to a spa at the beach and
he wants to go to a cabin in the
mountains it looks like at first glance
we're going on separate vacations not a
good idea or we're going to suffer each
other's like priorities but then if you
think about if I asked him like what's
your priority and he says well it's the
mountains and what if my priority is the
spa well then we cannot cut a deal where
we go to a spa in the mountains so
that's a very creative deal and a lot of
times negotiation is really about
understanding what are the other
people's priorities it's remarkable a
lot of people less than 10 of people
actually ask people what's your priority
it's remarkable and you know that's
that's you can't get to those win-win
agreements those creative agreements
without knowing that and one of the
tricks in negotiation is to not be too
competitive and not be too Cooperative
because if you're too Cooperative you
just split things down the middle right
there's a great story you might have
heard this from Maggie or near that like
two sisters negotiating over an orange
one of them wants the peel to make a
cake the other wants the pulp to eat it
if they just split that resource down
the middle one's going to toss out the
peel and the other one's gonna toss out
the pulp so the creative agreement there
is if they knew they had these different
values on the resource they would trade
off versus just splitting the difference
and wasting the resource so it's a
fascinating balance between being not
too competitive where you're just trying
to get that whole resource or take your
own vacation and not being too
Cooperative one of the things I like to
tell people and that I have like a list
of top 10 research findings on
negotiation on my website also um but
one of the things that we know is that
we should mind our metaphors so
metaphors are really not just a
linguistic device it's about how do you
map the domain of negotiation what is it
like to you so think about it is
negotiation like a game or a sport or a
battle or is it like dating right and I
think you know it's not just a
linguistic device we know that people
actually start thinking about
negotiation through metaphor without
realizing it they enact scripts or
behaviors communication strategies that
reflect those metaphors and they are
evaluating the situation based on those
metaphors and what we know is that we
need to match metaphors appropriately to
the context sometimes people use Uber
competitive metaphors like battle and
sports when it's actually an integrative
context like the vacation example
sometimes people use super relational
metaphors when it's a actually
competitive content text where you
should be claiming more value for
yourself so we try to help people think
about their metaphors and then negotiate
metaphors with their Partners try to
come up with a shared metaphor so that's
something I think is really an exciting
area of new research that we've been
working on I'll just mention one other
thing because I'm across cultural
psychologist so you know a lot of the
literature that we know all the findings
about negotiation many of them are from
the West they're from the US and they
work really well in our ecology where we
have very strong institutions and we
have a lot of Mobility where Swift trust
is really important trust but verify
those findings are not necessarily
applicable in places like the Middle
East or East Asia we do a lot of
research on negotiation try to
understand people's metaphors understand
what are we trying to get out of the
situation often we're not just
negotiating the tangibles the the salary
or the price we're negotiating something
deeper in for example the Middle East
where respect and honor are really
really important in fact we can show
that with some of our research we have a
new honor dictionary too we can assess
how much people talk about honor talk
and we can see how that predicts
agreements in Egypt and other contexts
and the US and so that's just to say
that we need to be culturally
intelligent and that's a real term CQ
it's it's different than IQ it's
different than EQ it predicts
negotiation Effectiveness in
Intercultural context better than IQ or
EQ and so it's really important a lot of
times when we we send people abroad we
send people abroad because of their
technical competence not because of
their cultural intelligence so whenever
I teach negotiation or talk about it we
always talk a lot about culture I I find
so many things fascinating about what
you've said this idea of negotiating the
metaphor sort of a meta-negotiation that
you have to have first is fascinating
and you have to align that first and the
point you made about understanding the
other person's perspective requires a
lot of listening I think people think of
negotiation as very active you're
speaking you know it's that used car
dealer negotiation yeah that's a
metaphor there we go and yet it's really
listening to understand what's important
for your the person you're negotiating
with that's really that's right I
totally agree most times people are like
thinking about how to influence other
people and they're even if they're
asking a question they're thinking about
what are they going to say next and we
try in our classes to say hey listening
is really important and if you feel
really vulnerable you don't want to ask
people about what their priorities or
you don't want to reveal your priority
then you have to ask questions
indirectly to get at that and that's
very important in cultures that have low
trust it is a really important skill
whether it's indirect or direct
listening absolutely and that last piece
you said about the cultural context of
negotiation I think is really important
this idea of cultural intelligence
Beyond just normal intelligence and
emotional intelligence I think is a
really fascinating one and as we become
even more Global in how we we work and
interact that becomes even more
important so we've talked about
negotiation conflict is another piece of
this puzzle as well I'm wondering if you
have suggestions and best practices
around how to manage conflict and this
can be between individuals between team
members or even organizations how can we
manage conflict and I'm taking notes I
have two teenagers I need help yeah
conflict you know are these rejected
claims they're they usually have a lot
of really negative emotions and I think
part of the issue that happens in
conflicts is that we become very
self-serving in our sense of what right
and wrong and we tend to associate
ourselves with Fair behaviors and we
tend to associate other people with
unfair Behavior so we rarely think about
how is I unfair in that situation how
are they fair in fact we can document
just how pervasive this self-serving
bias of fairness is in my classes I ask
people to come up with a list of things
when we think about Fair behaviors and
put the letter I if they do it more than
others and they if other people do it
more than them they do that for five
minutes and then they do the same thing
for unfair behaviors and then we have
them count how many behaviors they came
up with on both lists and in the U.S in
particular we see that people have huge
numbers of eye fair and they have huge
numbers of they unfair you know it's a
very pervasive bias in how we see the
world it's self-protective but what we
think we need to do here is how people
understand like think about how you
might have contributed to this conflict
think about how they might have been
fair so this is not also about empathy
and listening you know the other thing I
think along the issue of communication
and narrative we're starting to study
conflict as stories that people get very
attached to you and kind of the bias in
the stories they tell themselves and for
this we did a recent paper we were
probably familiar with the telephone
game yes and we were looking at how
people transmit conflicts over chains of
people it's one of my favorite studies
it really is realistic because what we
did in the first chain we had two
parties in conflict that were of equal
blame and we pilot tested so each of
them there was issues like between two
apartments having a conflict in terms of
parking and noise and garbage and
whatnot but they were both equally to
blame and then we had each person in one
condition they would didn't know either
of the apartment buildings and they
reproduced the story to another person
and then that person reproduced to
another and down to four people in
another condition they knew one of the
apartments they knew the people in the
apartments and we had them do the same
thing it was remarkable to see over the
chains how that group who had a
motivated kind of stake in the conflict
started weaving out details of their own
blame their own groups and they started
embellishing the blame of the out group
and as this conflict was reproduced
across the chain they were getting more
eventual
and you know what's fascinating so when
you someone tells you a story and I ask
all your audience to think about this
when someone gives you a story about a
conflict
think about it as a story and think
about it about what are they weaving out
what are they embellishing even that
they don't even realize it it's not
something conscious that we don't think
people realize they were doing this and
in fact we've done some more recent
research with uh Partners relational
Partners
um because actually by accident when we
go to our spouses or to our friends and
we tell them about a conflict we choose
people that are going to help validate
those conflicts this is kind of the dark
side of empathy I told you Todd as a
lawyer and he said I'll go at home and
tell them about a conflict and he's
always like really is you sure that
happened and I'm like listen dude I want
empathy here so we always like to
negotiate like first it gives me a
little empathy but then he tries to poke
holes in my story and I think it's
really important in a recent study we
showed that naturally people really like
to have empathy in their conflicts but
the more their Partners empathize with
them the more eventual they become of
the person they're in conflict with so
we're trying to figure out you know how
do we help manage that process of
conflict but that's just to broadly say
that self-serving biases are really
rampant in Conflict situations how we
perceive ourselves and others how we
tell stories about this and what we're
leaving at and what we're embellishing I
find a lot of what you have shared with
us really has us challenge the way that
we see and do the work we do how we
negotiate how we experience conflict and
the role that communication narrative
listening plays in it is so critical
this notion of a dark side of empathy I
find fascinating because everybody's
always talking about you want to be more
empathetic but I can certainly see how
in my own life when I'm in Conflict I
search out the people who are going to
support my point of view which only
hardens my point of view and makes me
more revengeful or upset at the people
I'm In conflict with so thank you thank
you for having me
[Music]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Michael Riley and me Matt
Abrahams
for more information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
find us on social media at Stanford GSB
thank you